THE SHOW, BACK IN 2007 FORWARD,
JOURNALISM IS DEAD, IT IS GONE,
IT IS BURIED.
HERE WITH REACTION, THE MAN
HIMSELF, VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, MIKE PENCE.
MR. VICE PRESIDENT, THANK YOU
FOR BEING WITH US.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU, SEAN.
>> Sean: OKAY, WHILE I CAN
IMAGINE THAT YOU’VE GOT A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT TREATMENT THAN
KAMALA HARRIS, BUT LET’S STICK
TO SUBSTANCE AND THE ISSUES
HERE.
I THINK THAT’S IMPORTANT.
I ARGUE THIS WILL BE THE BIGGEST
CHOICE ELECTION, EPPING POINT
ELECTION EVEN IN HISTORY.
YOUR INITIAL REACTION?
>> Vice President Pence: WELL,
THE STATES IN THIS ELECTION HAVE
NEVER BEEN HIGHER.
FOLLOWING JOE BIDEN’S DECISION
TO NAME CALIFORNIA LIBERAL LIKE
KAMALA HARRIS TO THE TICKET, THE
CHOICE HAS NEVER BEEN CLEARER.
FOUR YEARS AGO WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLED AND ASKED
ME TO JOIN THIS TICKET, I SAID
YES IN A HEARTBEAT BECAUSE I
BELIEVED IN HIS VISION TO
REBUILD OUR MILITARY, TO REVIVE
OUR ECONOMY BY CUTTING TAXES,
ROLLING BACK REGULATION,
FIGHTING FOR FREE, FAIR TRADE,
UNLEASHING AMERICAN ENERGY,
STANDING UP FOR LIFE AND LIBERTY
AND APPOINTING CONSERVATIVES TO
OUR COURTS AND STANDING WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT AT EVERY LEVEL.
AND JOE BIDEN’S DECISION TO ADD
KAMALA HARRIS TO THE TICKET
CONFIRMS EVERYTHING
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I HAVE BEEN
SAYING, AND THAT IS THAT
JOE BIDEN AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAVE BEEN
OVERTAKEN BY THE RADICAL LEFT.
KAMALA HARRIS, LIKE JOE BIDEN,
SUPPORTS HIGHER TAXES,
SOCIALIZED MEDICINE, OPEN
BORDERS, ABORTION ON DEMAND AND
WERE JOE BIDEN SAID HE BE
WILLING TO CUT FUNDING TO
POLICE, SHE SAID RECENTLY THAT
SHE THOUGHT THAT WE SHOULD
REIMAGINE THE POLICE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AND I JUST HAVE TO TELL YOU.
YOU KNOW, I LIKE THE MATCHUP.
IT’S ON, SEAN.
I CAN’T WAIT TO GET BACK OUT
THERE.
I WILL BE IN IOWA TOMORROW
TELLING THE STORY OF WHAT THIS
PRESIDENT HAS DONE, HOW WE MADE
THIS COUNTRY STRONGER, MORE
PROSPEROUS IN OUR FIRST THREE
YEARS, HOW PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
SEEN US THROUGH THE WORST
PANDEMIC IN 100 YEARS AND HOW
WE’VE ALREADY CREATED MORE JOBS
IN THE LAST THREE MONTHS THAN
JOE BIDEN AND BARACK OBAMA
CREATED IN THEIR EIGHT YEARS IN
OFFICE.
I’M EXCITED TO TELL THE STORY.
I THINK KAMALA HARRIS BEING
ADDED TO THE TICKET JUST
CONFIRMS WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND I HAVE BEEN SAYING ALL
ALONG.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW,
MR. VICE PRESIDENT, FOUR YEARS
AGO -- LOOK, I’M NOW 33 YEARS IN
RADIO, IF YOU CAN BELIEVE IT.
I KNOW I LOOK SO MUCH YOUNGER,
MY 25TH YEAR AT FOX.
AND YOU KNOW, I SAID TO THIS
AUDIENCE, AND I HAVE TO ALWAYS
BE HONEST, SAID DONALD TRUMP,
I’VE KNOWN HIM FOR ABOUT 25
YEARS NOW.
I SAID HE WILL GOVERN AS A
CONSERVATIVE.
EVERY ISSUE YOU JUST MENTIONED,
IT IS TRANSFORMATIONAL AND AS
MUCH AS HE KEPT EVERY PROMISE,
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM,
THERE’S NOT ONE THING HE SAID
THAT HE WANTED TO GET DONE THAT
REALLY HAS NOT GOTTEN DONE.
AND I LOOK AT IT AND THEN I LOOK
AT THE RESULTS AND RESULTS
MATTER TO ME.
I CAN’T THINK OF A SINGLE
ACCOMPLISHMENT OF JOE BIDEN IN
50 YEARS OF THE SWAMP THAT
HELPED BENEFIT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, CAN YOU?
AND I KNOW KAMALA HARRIS IS
GOING TO BE OUT THERE ATTACKING
THE PRESIDENT DAILY.
IF I WERE HIM I WOULD IGNORE
EVERYWHERE HE SAYS AND FOCUS ON
WHAT HE’S DONE WHAT HE PLANS TO
DO.
>> Vice President Pence: I
THINK THAT’S THE REASON WHY YOU
SEE THE SUPPORT ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND FOR THIS PRESIDENT
AND FOR OUR ADMINISTRATION AND
THAT’S WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
DONE, EXACTLY WHAT HE TOLD THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHAT HE WOULD DO
DO.
REBUILD THE MILITARY, RESTORE
THE ARSENAL OF DEMOCRACY AND NOW
AMERICA’S MILITARY IS STRONGER
THAN EVER BEFORE.
BUT THIS PRESIDENT, BY CUTTING
TAXES, BY ROLLING BACK MORE
REGULATIONS THAN ANY PRESIDENT
IN AMERICAN HISTORY, BY FIGHTING
FOR THE KIND OF FREE AND FAIR
TRADE LIKE THE USMCA, THAT WAS A
WIN FOR AMERICAN MANUFACTURERS,
WIN FOR AMERICAN FARMERS, A
TRADE DEAL THAT KAMALA HARRIS
WAS ONE OF ONLY TEN MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE TO VOTE AGAINST, AND
YOU SEE HIS COMMITMENT TO FOLLOW
THROUGH ON APPOINTING
CONSERVATIVES AT EVERY LEVEL IN
THE COURTS.
CONTRAST THAT WITH NO JOE BIDEN,
KAMALA HARRIS.
THEY WANT TO RACE TAXES BY
$4 TRILLION, THEY WANT TO DO
THEIR OWN VERSION OF THE GREEN
NEW DEAL, BUT TO TRILLION DOLLAR
MASSIVE ENVIRONMENTAL AGENDA.
THEY ARE GOING TO APPOINT
ACTIVISTS TO OUR COURTS, SUPPORT
TAXPAYER FUNDING OF ABORTION.
THEY SUPPORT OPEN BORDERS AND
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS
BEYOND ALL OF THAT, WITH
EVERYTHING THAT’S HAPPENING IN
CHICAGO AND NEW YORK AND
PORTLAND AND SEATTLE, YOU HAVE
IN PRESIDENT TRUMP A LEADER WHO
IS STANDING WITHOUT APOLOGY WITH
THE MEN AND WOMEN OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND IN JOE BIDEN
AND KAMALA HARRIS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE RADICAL
LEFT, YOU HAVE PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT CUTTING FUNDING TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT, A PARTY THAT’S
ADVOCATING DEFUNDING
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE CHOICE COULD NOT BE CLEARER
AND AS I SAID, I CAN’T WAIT TO
GET OUT THERE, GET OUT THERE AND
TELL THAT STORY, AND I THINK THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
VOTE FOR FOUR MORE YEARS OF
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Sean: MR. VICE PRESIDENT, I
THINK I’M A PRETTY GOOD
POLITICAL OBSERVER AND IF YOU
NOTICE THE DEBATE WHEN
KAMALA HARRIS WENT AFTER
JOE BIDEN ON HIS RACIAL
POSITIONS, WHICH ART -- IMAGINE
IF DONALD TRUMP SUPPORTED THE
GUY THAT FILIBUSTERED THE CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT AND TALKED ABOUT NOT
WANTING HIS KIDS TO BE INVOLVED
IN INTEGRATION OR "A RACIAL
JUNGLE," I CAN IMAGINE THE MEDIA
WOULD HAVE VERY DIFFERENT
REACTION TO JOE BIDEN.
AND AS I LOOK AT THE SCENE, IT’S
ACTUALLY ON THE SCREEN RIGHT
NOW, SHE, TO ME, AND YOU WILL BE
DEBATING HER, IT LOOKED TO ME
LIKE THAT LINE WAS PREPARED,
THAT LINE WAS MEMORIZED AND THAT
LINE WAS DELIVERED SOMEWHAT
PERFECTLY, PRETTY DEVASTATING TO
JOE BIDEN, AND LESS SHE FEELS
VERY DIFFERENTLY NOW,
APPARENTLY.
DID YOU GET THE SAME FEELING I
DID THAT THAT WAS ALL PREPARED
AHEAD OF TIME?
>> Vice President Pence: WELL,
LOOK, I THINK -- YOU KNOW, I
THINK SHE IS A SKILLED DEBATER,
BUT I CAN’T WAIT TO GET TO
SALT LAKE CITY AND BEYOND THE
STAGE WITH HER TO COMPARE
JOE BIDEN’S NEARLY 50 YEARS IN
PUBLIC LIFE, THE AGENDA OF THE
RADICAL LEFT, THE AGENDA THAT
SHE HAS EMBRACED THROUGHOUT HER
POLITICAL CAREER WITH THE
RESULTS OF THIS PRESIDENT AND
THIS ADMINISTRATION.
I MEAN, JOE BIDEN AND
KAMALA HARRIS COME FROM A PARTY
THAT’S BEEN TALKING ABOUT
HELPING AFRICAN-AMERICANS FOR
DECADES.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO BECAUSE
OF THE POLICIES WE ADVANCED --
WE ACTUALLY SAW THE LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT EVER RECORDED FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
WE SAW THE CREATION OF THOUSANDS
OF OPPORTUNITY ZONES AND
CREATING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
INVESTMENT IN OUR INNER CITIES.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO DOUBLED
THE SCHOOL CHOICE PROGRAM HERE
IN OUR NATION’S CAPITAL AND HAS
BEEN FIGHTING FOR EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EVERY AMERICAN
AMERICAN, ESPECIALLY OUR
MINORITY COMMUNITIES AND THAT’S
A RECORD THAT I’M EXCITED TO
TALK ABOUT.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO’S BEEN
OUT THERE FIGHTING FOR THE
AMERICAN DREAM FOR EVERY
AMERICAN REGARDLESS OF RACE OR
CREED OR COLOR AND WHILE THE
OTHER SIDE DOES THE TALKING, WE
ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
WE’VE DONE FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND WHAT WE ARE GOING TO
DO WITH FOUR MORE YEARS OF
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Sean: I WOULD LIKE TO, YOU
KNOW -- I WOULD LIKE TO NOT HAVE
ONE VOTE CAST UNTIL AT LEAST ONE
DEBATE BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT AND
JOE BIDEN.
JOE BIDEN SAYS HE CAN’T WAIT,
SAYS HE WANTS TO DO IT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS OFFERED TO
HAVE ONE, 16 STATES WILL BE
VOTING -- EARLY VOTING BEFORE
THE FIRST DEBATE.
I THINK THAT HAS TO CHANGE, DO
YOU AGREE?
>> Vice President Pence:
THERE’S NO QUESTION.
AND I KNOW THE CAMPAIGN IS
REACHING OUT.
PARTICULARLY IN THE TIMES IN
WHICH WE LIVE, AS WE CONTINUE
EVERY DAY TO WORK TO PUT THE
CORONAVIRUS IN THE PAST, WE ARE
SEEING POSITIVE TRENDS ACROSS
THE SUN BELT.
WE ARE SEEING LEVELING TRENDS IN
OTHER STATES OF AROUND THE COUNT
MORE MEDICINES AND MORE
VACCINES.
TO YOUR POINT, SEAN, WE ARE
GOING TO BE SEEING STATES AROUND
THE COUNTRY START EARLY VOTING
IN A MATTER OF A MONTH OR SO AND
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
OUGHT TO HEAR FROM THIS
PRESIDENT AND HEAR FROM
JOE BIDEN ON THE STAGE TO TALK
ABOUT THEIR COMPETING VISIONS
FOR THIS COUNTRY, BECAUSE THEY
COULD NOT BE MORE DIFFERENT.
I MEAN, I TRULY DO BELIEVE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S VISION AND OUR
FIRST THREE YEARS WAS PROVEN
OUT.
I MEAN, WE MADE AMERICA MORE
PROSPEROUS THAN EVER BEFORE.
THIS PRESIDENT AND HIS POLITIES
WITH OUR ALLIES IN CONGRESS
CREATED THE CONDITIONS, THE MOST
PROSPEROUS ECONOMY IN THE
HISTORY OF THE WORLD.
AND WHEN THE CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC STRUCK, IT’S THAT SOLID
FOUNDATION THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
POURED THAT’S ALLOWED US TO ADD
9 MILLION JOBS BACK AS WE OPEN
UP THIS ECONOMY JUST IN THE LAST
THREE MONTHS ALONE.
AND AGAIN, JOE BIDEN -- I MEAN,
WHEN PEOPLE GO INTO THE VOTING
BOOTH ON NOVEMBER 3RD WHEN THEY
PARTICIPATE IN EARLY VOTING
BEFORE THEN, THEY DESERVE TO
KNOW THAT HERE AS OUR COUNTRY IS
COMING BACK FROM THIS MASSIVE
PANDEMIC THAT COST 22 MILLION
AMERICAN JOBS, JOE BIDEN AND
KAMALA HARRIS, THEIR
PRESCRIPTION IS TO RAISE TAXES
BY $4 TRILLION AND IMPOSE AN
AVALANCHE OF REGULATIONS LIKE
THE GREEN NEW DEAL ON THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY AND, YOU
KNOW -- IT’S NO REAL SURPRISE.
IT’S WHAT JOE BIDEN AND
BARACK OBAMA DID IN THEIR EIGHT
YEARS.
THEY TRIED TO TAX AND SPEND AND
REGULATE US INTO PROSPERITY, AND
THEY OVERSAW THE SLOWEST
ECONOMIC RECOVERY SINCE THE
GREAT DEPRESSION.
I WANT TO SAY IT AGAIN, SEAN.
IT’S REMARKABLE THAT BECAUSE OF
THE FOUNDATION PRESIDENT TRUMP
FORGED, WE’VE ACTUALLY SEEN THIS
ECONOMY CREATE MORE JOBS IN THE
LAST THREE MONTHS THEN JOE BIDEN
IN THE LAST ADMINISTRATION
CREATED IN THEIR ENTIRE EIGHT
YEARS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE TO
UNDERSTAND THOSE TWO COMPETING
DIVISIONS AND WHEN THEY DO I